At its most basic, Avengers: Infinity War
is a movie that follows the tyrannical Titan
Thanos getting his purple hands on the Infinity
Stones so he can activate the Infinity Gauntlet,
snap his fingers, and wipe out half the universe's
population.
But, spoiler alert, the film didn't actually
show him obtaining all six Infinity Stones.
He already had the Power Stone plugged into
his Gauntlet when the movie opened.
Infinity War explained Thanos' acquisition
of the gem through Thor, who revealed that
the mad Titan "decimated" the war-torn planet
of Xandar and captured the Power Stone.
"P----."
So why didn't fans get to see Thanos actually
do this in the film?
Co-directors Joe and Anthony Russo have the
definitive answer: With so many Infinity Stones
to focus on, one simply had to go.
During a Q&A session with students at Iowa
City High School, Joe Russo explained that
he and his brother thought the Power Stone
would be "one too many" to include in the
already super-sized flick, saying,
"There's so many stones [Thanos] has to collect
and you get into a trap and we thought, we
knew where it was in [Guardians of the Galaxy],
so it was easy to deal with it off screen."
The Power Stone was a crucial element in Guardians
of the Galaxy, with the universe-savers traversing
through space to acquire the gem and keep
it away from the Kree militarist Ronan the
Accuser.
Ultimately, the intergalactic military and
police force known as the Nova Corps wound
up protecting the stone at the end of the
film, unaware that Thanos was coming soon.
Anyone hoping to see Thanos' ravaging of Xandar
on the silver screen will be pleased to know
that Marvel Studios president Kevin Feige
previously teased it might be possible in
Guardians of the Galaxy Volume 3, since it's
part of the origin of Richard Rider, better
known as Nova.
Feige once told ComicBook.com,
"If we have a big board with a bunch of characters
that have more immediate potential, Nova is
on that board.
Because of the connection to the Guardians
universe, because there is more than one example
to pull from in the comics that are interesting.
And you're absolutely right, he was in the
earliest drafts of the [Guardians of the Galaxy]."
Whether or not Marvel fans will ever get to
witness Thanos snatching up the Power Stone
remains a mystery that only time can solve.
Thanks for watching!
Click the Looper icon to subscribe to our
YouTube channel.
Plus check out all this cool stuff we know
you'll love, too!